let's get you ready for week three
what's more likely style and let's begin
with the new england patriots and
hopefully bill belichick won't be
wearing that sweatshirt on the sidelines
or maybe hopefully he will raiders take
on the patriots in new england
julian edelman
reaches his career high of 179 receiving
yards which was set last week against
the seahawks where darren waller matches
his career high of 16 targets which was
set last week what's more like oh i
think if you're making me pick one of
those right there i'm going to go with
the darren waller thing i i am you know
and again i i wouldn't be shocked if
julianna got 100 yards and and got
around there again but you know when you
start to get to 180 for a guy like
julian edelman i don't think that's
really his type of game you know all
those deep passes it was awesome i mean
man is he tough
uh and you know cam newton was on fire
but darren waller is like the go-to guy
in the pass game for the uh las vegas
raiders and you could see last week he's
special now it'll be fun to watch this
game i think could be a lot of fun i do
you know i i'm certainly leaning towards
the patriots but i'll say i'm i'm a
little concerned with them the patriots
front seven not real big and it's kind
of slow and this raiders o line is one
of the best in football and can dominate
so that's where i think the game gets
tipped a little bit more even than maybe
we would even think but i'm going darren
waller what do you think
yeah this one's easy it's darren waller
i mean how long has julian edelman been
playing and he just reached a career
high of 179 last week chances of him
duplicating it back-to-back weeks fairly
slim darren waller the guy that has
become derek carr's security blanket for
good reason he can catch the ball throw
it to him let him catch it let him move
the chains and bill belichick talked
yesterday about what a match-up problem
darren waller is now he didn't practice
yesterday and this is one of those weird
they didn't practice because they played
monday night but they have to issue a
report so if they had practiced on
wednesday darren waller wouldn't have
practiced
we'll see on thursday whether or not he
actually practices but but he's got some
sort of an injury that caused him to
land on the report so that's something
to keep an eye on for this week all
right rams and bills a couple of
two-and-oh teams what's more likely josh
allen throws for 300 yards or the rams
rush for 175 chris
wow
well i can't say that i i
sitting here right now i can't imagine
the rams and mcveigh running for 175 or
more on a sean mcdermott buffalo bills
defense i would be
i think shocked by that
and i i got respect for this rams
defense too but i just feel like with
josh allen the way he's playing the way
brian dayball the offensive coordinator
is calling plays right now which is like
attack we're not looking for three yard
gains we're looking for 30 yard gains
every play and that and then the
receivers they have around i think i
feel like it's more likely that allen
throws for 300 yards rather than the
rams rushing for 175.
yeah here's the thing and and just by
the way background josh allen had never
thrown for 300 yards he's done it in
both of the first two games of the
season and the rams running game is
averaging 172 yards per contest the
problem is
malcolm brown's got a broken finger now
they expect him to play with the broken
finger had surgery on it monday cam
akers has that separated rib cartilage
issue neither brown nor acres practiced
on wednesday it falls to daryl henderson
at that point so they may not have their
full complement of running backs to get
to 175 uh which you know hey maybe
henderson could yeah that's the thing
when you've got multiple guys yeah it's
down to one guy maybe one guy has a huge
day right but i'm more confident in josh
allen getting 300 yards again i hey look
he's he's on the front end of a special
season
and uh they're going to dial it up and
they're going to throw the ball and i
know he's got to deal with aaron donald
and jaylen ramsey but that's just two
out of 11. there's nine other guys that
are going to have to figure out how to
slow down that bill's offense and i'm
not sure they can slow it down to the
point where they can keep josh allen
under 300 chris yeah no i i mean from
what we've seen to this point so far
it's been one of the more fun teams to
watch in all of football and
just
josh allen they've they've entrusted him
with the the keys to the franchise you
know throwing the ball backed up on the
one-yard line last week throwing the
ball you know when you're supposed to be
running the clock out and like you think
oh it's mcdermott they'll run the clock
out punt and try to win the game with
the defense nope attack mode i mean
diggs has been phenomenal that look
that's looking like the move of the
off-season right now for any team uh i
mean that that's been special so yeah
i'm having fun watching it and this is
going to be a great game this is one of
the under the radar really great
matchups of the weekend
yeah given what stephon diggs has
brought to the buffalo offense and what
he's taken away from the minnesota
offense what a swing right bills 2-0
vikings 0-2 the texans are owen 2. they
get to go to pittsburgh where the
steelers are 2-0 deshaun watson with two
or more touchdown passes or tj watt with
two or more sacks what's more likely i'm
going tj watt i mean you know i could
see both happening certainly i mean it's
but but if you're gonna make me pick one
of the other i'm going with tj watt you
know first off the texans offense is
spotty right now this is a very good
steelers defense as we know
and
we've seen protection issues a little
bit with houston once again i did not
think they would be you know
coming about here
i thought they had some of these things
figured out but it's two weeks in a row
he's got people around him that's still
a work in progress obviously up front
and then this is a great pass rush i
mean dupree has been awesome watt has
been awesome i mean they really are i
don't know is there a better pass
rushing duo than those two out there
right now if there is i don't know who
it is but uh i'm going watt two plus
sacks
well and dupree took over the first game
of the season and watts taking over the
second game of the season and and here's
the thing if the steelers build a lead
it's conducive to more pass rush i want
to see the steelers do a better job of
holding the lead though i was i was
dismayed by the way the steelers let the
broncos back in the game last week and
that that came down to the wire a hell
of a lot more uh seriously for the
steelers than it should have they could
have lost that game and they could have
lost to the giants they could be owen
too
now um you know hey their defense
ultimately made the plays when they had
to and that's the key if you can trust
your defense to step up with the bud
dupreeh hit on daniel jones when the
giants are about to take the lead late
in the third quarter after a long
drive that that wore out the defense and
when terrell edmonds can be
trusted to bust through and sack jeff
driscoll to to disrupt a play that that
could have ended in a touchdown that
would have given the broncos the wind
then then you you know that those close
games are going to go your way so i got
much more faith in this dealers defense
and in tj watt he's the afc defensive
player of the week he's he's uh got two
and a half sacks all from last week tied
for the nfl lead this season and watson
has already been sacked eight times this
year cowboys and seahawks get together
what's more likely russell wilson's mvp
odds improve after this game or dak
prescott's mvp odds improve as of right
now wilson is the favorite he has jumped
to the top of the stack at three to one
patrick mahomes five to one along with
lamar jackson there's oh aaron rodgers
uh oh kyler murray creeping up i don't
know guys worked for him this year
that's that was the one bet because the
odds were like 20 25 to 1. that was the
one i really liked but i'll tell you
what he's gonna have to out duel russell
wilson twice to knock him after that
perch and even then you got to deal with
mahomes and jackson and rogers but
prescott's there at 20 to 1. what's
what's more likely
wilson's go uh lower or higher what is
it they go lower right the odds go lower
your odds improve right based upon this
week who's going to be in better
position according to the odds makers
who win mvp after good job better good
word i like that um man
that's a this is a tough one i i i
really think we could see
a track meet in this football game i
would not be shocked i mean you got
weapons galore you got two quarterbacks
you can throw the ball down the field
and are aggressive and then you got two
defenses that
you know the cowboys don't have any
playmakers and you've seen people kind
of move the ball on them through the
first two weeks and the seahawks have
some playmakers but they play like you
know their hair's on fire they're
they're coming after you they're gonna
give you chances you know that's why
we're liking seattle right now it's like
they're gonna make a play or you're
gonna go down and score and they're
going to get the ball back and russell
can you know cook it up
i guess i am going to go here i'm going
to go with dak prescott i am i could see
him as improving the
and this is why
not anything to do with the player more
to do with the systems they're playing
against dallas has been very
conservative on the defensive side of
the ball a lot of like just basic zone
coverages we're not going to let up a
big play
they actually played pretty good defense
last week i mean the falcons had five
short fields five short fields with all
that talent they got on their team and
they came away with two touchdowns and
three field goals that was a win for the
cowboys and it's because mike nolan's
got them doing basic stuff i think
seattle will lend itself to like all
right we can't sit back here anymore
we're sending jamal adams and bobby
wagner and we're going to give you a
chance to make a play and i just think
that's going to lead to maybe some big
time prescott numbers not necessarily
saying it's going to win but i think
it's going to have big time numbers
the uh over under for that game is 56
and i'm still a little gun shy because i
was convinced that texans chiefs would
sail over 54 and it landed right on 54
two weeks ago
but 56 seems a little low for this game
i think so because both offenses are
extremely potent both defenses have real
question marks how about this and let's
put that graphic back up on the screen
please given the current odds
who's your best bet who's the guy that
you would put chris some of your
discretionary income the income you use
for certain products that you may ingest
on a thursday night
who's the guy that you would put your
money on um i i i still have a hard time
um i mean to me it's still the top the
guys at the the top two right there i
mean i can't believe i'm saying that
because lamar sitting there and you know
my man aaron rodgers but wilson the way
he looks mahomes the problem with
mahomes is even when it's a crappy game
it's 315 yards and two of the most
unbelievable plays you've ever seen in
your life that's what's amazing i mean
that that's where you just go holy crap
yeah the chargers bottled up my homes
all the way to the point where he made
plays galore to carry them to win the
game right i mean that's where i just
i'm amazed by both of those guys
um so i'm going with those two and i'm
still gonna go with my homes i think
he's still the guy that i i would pin my
uh name to
i i i want something that's gonna pay
off now before i get to the real payoff
i think aaron rodgers eight to one is
going to shrink after sunday night
against the saints because we're going
to get to see him on national tv but the
last two how how could you overlook the
possibility of 30 to one odds for your
boy blue
josh you just asked me what do you know
what i felt best about if i wanted the
best bargain deal you're right maybe i
would try to do that that's the point
the best bet with factoring the money in
do you not listen i don't you just said
which one do you like the most that's it
i told you what i like the most
we can play we can play it back uh
obviously you're gonna like the ones
that are the lowest odds but from the
standpoint of of the potential return on
your investment 30 to one for cam newton
and josh that's insane
at 30 to one right now which one would
you would you put your money on oh
i think i'd put josh on josh allen right
now with the way that offense looks and
those weapons he has and i think he's
just determined and that's not easy to
say because cam newton's the same way
but i just think the weapons around
allen are a little bit better
all right sunday night football packers
in the saints as mentioned what's more
likely packers running back aaron jones
is the game's leading rusher or saints
running back alvin kamara emerges as the
top receiver oh um i i think i'm gonna
still go with aaron jones as the game's
top rusher you know alvin kamara again
we know there's going to be no michael
thomas you're right there's a chance he
can have a lot of yards and receptions
here
uh but i think also with the way green
bay is kind of attacking down the field
and i know devonte adams we're gonna see
where he is at right now he's
questionable for the game but still like
valdez scantling has been around 90
something yards 100 yards both games you
know and the way they're throwing the
ball off of play action being aggressive
i would just think that somebody on the
packers too
is gonna have a hundred yards or be in
that 90 range and i'm not so sure i feel
like kamara is definitely gonna camaro
is definitely gonna get there so i'm
gonna go with aaron jones games top
rusher
tough to be a top 10 receiver if you're
not available for the games chris i mean
i and i say that facetiously i know it
because of your omission of dante adams
right top 10 receivers list but last
year he had that injury suffered week
four against the eagles and it knocked
him out for a while and you know you've
got it you've got to be on the field
you've got to be racking up the numbers
if you're not racking up the numbers and
creating the highlights someone else is
and you get quickly forgotten so they
need him on sunday night for the offense
to be everything it is but i agree with
you i think that that aaron jones will
be the game's top rusher because they
will have that focus he had 168 rushing
yards last week and 68 receiving yards
to go with it he had an incredible
performance he's got the hot hand right
now he's chasing that contract let him
chase it let him run the ball and and
let him be that compliment to aaron
rodgers all right monday night football
huge early season game two-and-oh chiefs
against the two-and-oh ravens the ravens
trying to avenge one of their losses
from last year and get to 15 straight
regular season victories incredible
performance by the ravens in the regular
season
um
what's more likely
this will be the highest scoring game of
the week or it's lower scoring than we
expected ooh i
i really could 53 and a half yeah 53 and
a half i mean i could see this going
either way i really can
i could you know again i could see
baltimore going down the first drive of
the game scoring a touchdown now my
homes in kansas city feel like all right
well i guess we can't ease into this
game we got to attack and come right
back and all of a sudden we're in a
shootout i can just as easily though
just see like steve spagnullo and wink
bartondale having really good creative
schemes and like a game plan to where
both teams are a little bit early on
like whoa wait nobody's done this to us
before hold on how are we going to
attack how are we going to work from
here
i i think when it's all said and done
though i'm gonna go that it's
i'm gonna go lower scoring than we
expected because when we talk about the
highest scoring game of the week
i still think seattle and dallas would
lead that charge in my mind and i don't
know i just feel like we're expecting so
many points with these quarterbacks and
everything like this and there's a
little familiarity with these two teams
because they played each other a few
times the last few years i have a
feeling that the defenses are going to
step up and bring something new to the
table
51 points scored uh between the two
teams in 2018 when the ravens and chiefs
played it was 61 last year that overtime
contest the chiefs winning 33 to 28. how
is that no overtime was the year before
last year was 33 to 28 in in regulation
you're not going to have a five-point
margin that's the crazy thing with these
two teams though right like you you you
sit there and you go
you know oh
the offenses are kind of stalling out
and then it gets to the important part
of the game and it's like seven minutes
left and they can both score three
touchdowns in the last seven minutes
where you go this game was 17 all and
now it's going to end at 38.35 or
something crazy like that
that's where they're they're insane both
of these quarterbacks and offenses
but the chiefs offense continues to have
that element of sluggishness that emerge
for extended stretches of a game
remember the raiders game last year
early in the season they scored 28. they
scored all 28 in one second quarter
right zero in the other three right and
and they they were up
last week against the chargers you
talked about the the pass rush i mean
yep patrick mahomes was constantly
harassed and i think the ravens are
capable of doing that too yeah so
uh you know with i think that the
challenge is going to be for the chiefs
to avoid that funk because the ravens
don't the ravens aren't going to have a
lapse they're going to score and they're
going to score and they're going to
score and if you're not matching them
it's going to be a margin come the
fourth quarter that even patrick mahomes
can't erase it it could be it definitely
could be and this would be the our first
real test to look at that ravens pass
rush too i'm
excited to see what they got there
because that was one of the things that
they weren't great at last year just a
normal four-man pass rush
they have had to blitz and do creative
things and then you know fortunately
they have great corners in the back end
that can do that you know are the ravens
what i'm i'm interested to see the
approach
are you gonna blitz and try to pressure
my homes and then roll the dice on one
on ones on the outside with those
receivers against your great corners i
don't know or do you just go
okay we're going to kind of do what the
chargers did and try to play soft and do
that way and like ben don't break and
not lit up the big play that's not
really in the raven's dna that's not how
they play defense so
i'm very intrigued to see where it goes
what was your final answer do you think
this is the highest scoring game of the
week or lower scoring than i don't i
don't think it's a high scoring game of
the week i think seattle and dallas will
be and uh the the detroit arizona game
has an over under of like 55 yeah
yeah kind of surprising remember last
year they got together week one and
there was that 17 point margin oh what a
shock the lions blowing a big lead the
lions are becoming the poor man's
falcons because at least the falcons win
some games and have some accomplishments
the lions don't but both are becoming
well known for blowing leads and i don't
think they're going to get a chance to
blow the lead this time against the new
and improved arizona cardinals with kyle
murray and company so i don't think
it'll be the highest scoring game of the
week but you know there's hey
uh sunday night game
monday night game
a couple of good prime time games and
then the late afternoon game seahawks
cowboys
good games in week three yeah they're
very good games in week three
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports